so something that I love to do is Google
the daily virtuals of my favorite author
scientist and artists this most likely
comes from the belief that if one
redesigns their life to be similar to
their favorite artist one could become
like them however something that I
learned by reading about these prolific
people is that the way they plan their
days differs greatly if we for example
look at the wake-up time of famous
writers we can see that this lies
anytime between 4 am such as Haruki
murakami and 2PM Charles Bukowski thus
the details of your day do not matter
but having a moment every day where you
create something makes all the
difference so hi I'm Charlotte rasa a
third year PhD student in computational
neuroscience and today I want to take
you along in planning my 2023 and
hopefully help you to plan yours a
little bit as well so something that I
like to do is actually not focus on
goals but focus on systems so at the end
of the year I kind of review the systems
that I had in place the previous year
and try to make updates and see if I can
improve them such that I would in the
ideal case reach the goals that I have
set for myself because as James Clear
said you do not rise to the level of
your goals you fall to the level of your
systems and I really agree with this I
think we sometimes can set really lofty
goals but our goals oftentimes don't
really depend on us but can also depend
a lot on outside forces whereas if we
set systems we usually ensure that at
least the lowest parts of our goals
should be met if we keep on following
the system that we have set so how does
one go about to you setting these kind
of systems so a book I read lately was
the 12-week year I recommend by the way
and in this book they kinda go over the
idea that if you want to set your goals
you need to set them more in the
immediate future and I kind of extend
this idea to if you want to set your
systems you kind of need to look more to
the immediate future and not a year from
now so what they do in the book is they
go over this method of how to set your
goals and systems for 12 weeks such that
you may get the goals that you would
normally set for one year in 12 weeks so
there are three steps in this method
that I will go over so step one is to
just think of the things that you would
like to have achieved in in the next 12
weeks so you can select anywhere between
one or three goals so one of the goals I
for example have is to write a blog post
every week on my website which is also
linked down below so I've created this
website about a year ago I think and
I've said this goal many times that I
wanted to write a blog post every week
about something related to computational
Neuroscience or the way I study kind of
similar to this YouTube channel but a
little bit more more focused on
computational Neuroscience I think but
what I kind of realized over the last
year is that even though I set the goals
I haven't I didn't really set the
systems that would allow this goal to be
accomplished so after you decided your
priority or your goal you can go to step
two which is called back casting so back
casting is a planning method that starts
with defining a desirable future and
then Works backwards to identify
policies and programs that will connect
to that specified future to the presence
the fundamental question of best back
casting asks if we want to attain a
certain goal what actions must be taken
to get there so I'm gonna take you over
how I do back casting and I'm going to
use this board from Miro so mirrors does
website that allows you to use all these
different kind of ports and planning
strategies and I've been really enjoying
using them so as you can see the
assistance are your overview of the
method so they really put it down in
tiny sections so I'm gonna take you over
each step and hopefully you can learn
something so the first step that you
want to do is to Define your future so
in this case the future that I want to
have is I want to have 12 vlog post at
the end of 12 weeks then the second step
based on your goal you want to think of
positive decisions you could make that
could help you accomplish this goal and
you want to think of negative decisions
or situation that would disallow you to
get this goal so for example a negative
development for me that I noticed last
year is not having enough time another
negative thing that could happen is like
ideas if I don't have enough ideas to
write about that would definitely
disallow me to these blog posts so a
positive driver for me is to for example
work on it on a set time so work time to
schedule like I said work time also by
the way you can select all these
background colors so I selected this
palette because I think this palette is
really beautiful so another positive
thing that I could do that would allow
me to write every single week is to have
deadlines to be honest if I have a
deadline for me that works really well I
know for some people that doesn't work
that well but for me it works very well
and the last thing is also to read every
week something that I could write about
as well so to read interesting papers or
to try to take some more courses on
computational neuroscience and these
kind of things so the last thing you
would then do is to really try to
visualize if you start from having
written 12 blog posts in the future and
then work your way backwards through
your life in these 12 weeks and they
have this visual representation with a
timeline but I actually also just like
to do it by closing my eyes and
Imagining the future and then working my
way backwards but so for example I wrote
every Monday that's a positive thing
that happened just before then something
negative that happened I went to a party
and or it's not negative but I didn't
have enough time to write my blog post
by doing this I think you actually
really get a sense of what needs to be
done to get to the place that you want
and a second thing is that you will also
become really realistic of the things
that could happen because a lot of times
the reason that we don't get to our
goals or we don't have our systems
correctly in place is that we don't like
to imagine a negative future or a future
that's not optimal but I think by being
really realistic about the things that
could happen the chances of you actually
reaching the future goals that you want
increase by manifolds so then step three
is to really design your systems so
you've now made your goal really clear
you've really thought about the future
and all the things that could occur so
the third step is to make your systems
that would really allow you to restore
your goals so the thing I like to do
when I'm designing my system is actually
to design my environment so the way I
like to think of designing your
environment is designing your
environment in time space and with
technology which is also a form of space
but I will keep that separate so the
first thing I do is design my
environment in time so for example for
my environment in time if I want to
write my blog post I every week I have
to have scheduled time blocks throughout
the week that where I will be writing
this blog post so for example I would
time block certain periods in a week
that would allow me to write so that's
my design in time so the next one is to
design your environment so for example
um if I want to write I would need like
a good space to write so I like to do it
at home at my desk and I kind of set up
the ideal environment for me to be able
to write and another design choice I
like to make for environment it's like
your sound environment so I usually also
pick like a good playlist for example or
a certain soundtrack that really gets me
in that mood for writing and then to
design your technology so personally I
like this the most to kind of redesign
all the technology that you use so I
remove all the apps that are not
conductive for me writing in this case
and I add apps that I think are
conductive so apps that I use for
writing are notion for example I also
use a Pomodoro Timer to time myself when
I'm writing and that's almost it I don't
need that much for uh writing and the
thing I liked most actually about the
12-week year system is the reflection
period at the end so what people usually
do is they only reflect in January for
example and set New Year's resolutions
but by having a 12-week system or even a
four-week system like the amount of
weeks doesn't really matter but you have
more periods in a year where you are
re-reflecting on the decisions you have
made so sometimes what I've noticed is
that throughout the year the kind of
goals are the kind of things that I want
actually fluctuates quite a lot so for
example maybe during summer I'm more
interested in sports exercise being
outside whereas in Winter maybe I'm more
interested in being with family cooking
and enjoying studying for example and I
think these fluctuations are actually
kind of fine it's just part of Being
Human but I also think it's good to be
aware of how you are changing throughout
timing so yeah these were my tips for
setting systems and goals for 2023 if
you have any lofty calls for 23 I would
be really curious or if you're one of
those people that doesn't set New Year's
resolutions I would also be really
curious as to your reason why and
otherwise see you next week bye